[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream i forgot to check what number but
i think it might be 89 is it doctor
hines it is indeed 89
live stream 89 that's really something
um
all right we have a lot to talk about
today we have some announcements up top
we have a couple of ads and then we will
get to the uh
the meat of the matter indeed indeed um
so this week we're going to talk a bit
about
um uh well we're going
you're going to speak a little bit to uh
the sam harris episode that came out
yesterday along with eric topel
um and we're going to talk some about
natural immunity
to to uh to covid and some
about uh the emergency use
authorizations
and then we are going to as as has
become our want we are working chapter
by chapter through
uh the book of ours that is forthcoming
a hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century that will be out
in september of this year one chapter
per week up until the launch date um
they're all on very different topics all
uh exploring some aspect of humanity
with an evolutionary lens
this week's uh chapter is sleep so we'll
be talking
hopefully not soporific uh i think i
think it won't be we're specifically i'm
specifically gonna read an excerpt and
we're going to talk about other aspects
of sleep too
but we're specifically going to read an
excerpt on dreams and hallucinations
yeah so i think that should be that
should be fun
so um announcements
as usual if you are watching on youtube
consider switching over to odyssey
and both both are live streaming right
now and both will be
up into perpetuity unless youtube sees
fit to change that
and the new q a system is live so we are
no longer looking at super chat
questions on youtube
uh the directions to the audience
involve
going to darkhorsesubmissions.com and
there you will find everything you need
to know in order to
ask questions uh that we will try to get
to
in the second hour we do this for an
hour hour and a half and then we take a
break
and then we come back for the live q a
and that's when we get to your questions
uh there are no uh no promises that we
will get to yours but we uh
we try to prioritize the ones that uh
that come in the most
topically uh at the highest monetary
value and the ones that we are the most
interested in uh please
consider joining our patreons many have
of late and we appreciate it especially
given the
um the messing with our uh
our financial baseline that some of the
uh
some of the big tech platforms have been
doing
tomorrow is our monthly private two-hour
q a on my patreon so that's at 11 a.m
pacific tomorrow all the questions for
that have already been asked but uh
that's a small enough group that we're
actually able to look at the chat as it
happens and interact with with people in
the chat and it's a lot of fun we
actually really enjoy it
uh we've got uh as of a couple weeks ago
we've got some new
shirts goliath shirts uh at uh
at the store.darkhorsepodcast.org
including a lot of stuff in short sleeve
that when we first put it out was only
in long sleeve
and after we do ads we will uh tell you
who the additional sponsors of today's
episode are i'll give you a hint it's
number 89 and the letter d
yeah but we'll get there yes we will get
we'll get there after the ad so today's
sponsors are relief band and public
goods
[Music]
first relief band i'm going to talk to
you about this product which can help
with nausea
relief band first though i want to say a
few words about
nausea under ancient circumstances and
some modern ones too nausea was
generally a useful signal that something
is off you've eaten something you
shouldn't have
or near something that's emanating a bad
smell itself a signal that you shouldn't
get near it
in modernity we still need to track our
bodily sensitivities we should not
always choose to simply erase discomfort
including nausea whenever we feel it
that said some of modernity creates
nausea that does no good at all
travel sickness especially when there is
nothing to be done about it you're on a
plane or a boat
can be agonizing for instance and
getting some relief from that would be
lovely
enter relief band relief band is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more
now that's the list from relief band and
this is a product that we are endorsing
but i will parenthetically say that that
morning sickness should first be dealt
with by trying to figure out what it is
that is making you nauseous and keeping
that out of your diet and a better way
of for instance of dealing with
hangovers
is to drink a lot of water while you
drink the alcohol but if you mess that
up and you got a hangover relief band
can apparently help
relief band is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
provides all-natural relief with those
side effects for as long as needed
technology was developed over 20 years
ago in hospitals to help patients with
nausea but is now available
over the counter to treat nausea and
vomiting
we happen to be lucky we don't neither
of us really suffers from nausea but a
good friend is not so lucky
and she had this to say about her
experience with relief band
quote i used to have nausea on a near
daily basis from both anxiety and the
need to take regular medication
relief bands relieved my nausea in less
than three minutes without the side
effects i was experiencing from
anti-nausea medication they have
entirely changed my life for the better
so as you're getting ready to take that
summer road trip hop on that boat or are
nauseous for other reasons we've got
good news right now relief band has an
exclusive offer just for darkhorse
listeners
if you go to reliefband.com and use
promo code dark promo
code darkhorse you'll receive 20 off
plus free shipping and a no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee
so head to r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use our promo code darkhorse
for 20
off plus free shipping you know i always
used to think that
the relief band was the band that filled
in if the headlining band had drunk too
much
the night before but of course if they
had relief bans that might not be such
an issue apparently
right there you go all right on to
public goods
public goods can simplify your life as a
one-stop shop for high quality everyday
essentials their ingredients are
carefully sourced and affordable
public goods has towels glassware and
sponges razors and shampoo
toilet paper mustard coffee coconut oil
and they've got niche items like bone
broth concentrate and gluten-free pasta
and small batch marshmallows ethically
sourced from small marshes
public goods products have a great
design too the aesthetic is simple and
clean
there are no garish colors and this is
such an important point if you're going
to have dish soap sitting on your
counter you don't want it calling
attention to itself
finally your subscription service is
efficient and simple
and easy to use public goods members can
buy all of their premium essentials in
one place
it really is an everything store for
dark horse listeners
we have the following offer receive 15
off your first public goods order with
no minimum purchase
there are they are so confident that you
will absolutely love their products and
come back again and again that they are
giving
you fifteen dollars to spend on your
first pub uh purchase
go to publicgoods.com darkhorse and use
the code
darkhorse at checkout uh that's public
goods p
u b l i c g o o d s dot com
forward slash dark horse to receive 15
off your first order
very good now um sometimes since we've
been reading from chapters of the book
we have suggested an episode
brought to you by a certain letter um a
law sesame street uh we felt
and uh you know we felt that youtube was
treating us and answered the whole world
i feel like i have fur all over me um a
bit like
we were we were the target audience for
sesame street so
uh today's episode brought to you by the
number 89 and the letter d
this is what d from the index of our
book sounds like you want me to be wild
eyed
a little bit wild just a little bit
lightly crazed just slightly crazy okay
darwin
charles dawkins richard deepwater
horizon oil spill
delano laura dennis ovens design
constraint tradeoffs duval fronds
diaphragm
diarrhea dickens charles diet seafood
dimensional lumber and visual
perception diminishing returns dinosaurs
disease risk and birth month
diurnal diverse views experience in
places hmm experiences in places
exposure to
division of labor in agriculturalist
societies differences between sexes and
gendered work
and in hunter-gatherer societies and
modern society
monogamy anne that was all division of
labor dobchansky theodosius
dogs dolphins dreams drugs and children
duck bill platypus
and ducks awesome
yeah it's the denisovans that really
sell it it's the denisovans i think the
duck-billed platypus kind of get us
there too there's two different
references to duckbill platypus in this
book
do you think other platypuses feel left
out by the focus
on duck-billed platypuses well and so i
made this observation the other day and
i have not vetted this at all with
anything in the literature and i'm sure
this is an observation that's been made
by phylogenetic systematists
that i was looking at uh a bunch of
geese with goslings and these were older
goslings and they looked for all the
world like a number of
species of adult female ducks
and i thought that there might be within
the united's the the geese and the ducks
um be some pedomorphouses going on so um
you know i don't think that there are in
fact any other build platypuses but i
would expect
they might be goosebuild platypuses if
there were some that was what that long
ridiculous setup was that long
ridiculous
yeah i don't think there are any other
platypi
i'm going to get male on that one i have
a feeling but uh
yes i do know uh that the platypus when
uh specimens were sent back to europe
was thought to be a hoax because of
course
um you know pretty bad one too hoaxing
biologists used to be a much bigger
thing right now
they're looking for the staples right
exactly it did look like somebody had uh
had glued a bill on a
a mammal and tried to pass it off well
also i mean the spurs the poisonous
spurs
and the spurs on the on the feet yeah
that tail no the whole thing's
ridiculous this thing is ridiculous and
then eggs
eggs come out of this thing eggs yeah
right exactly exactly all right come on
but they do exist i really am eager
uh to see them in the wild it's one of
the animals i most want and not just
because it's super
weird but because they're actually
ecologically very fascinating
yeah and they've got um it's unclear
i actually i don't remember it's the
echidnas there's like three to five
species of echidnas depending on how
lumpy or splitty you're feeling that day
and one species of platypus and those
are the monotremes what i used to call
the wacky mammals um the the egg-laying
mammals
and um they have like eight or ten pairs
of sex chromosomes i thought it was five
but it's definitely a large
it's larger it's different between the
species of monotremes as few species of
monotremes as there are it's different
between them
yeah i think the five is the platypus no
it's not that low it's not
all right well we're certainly going to
get some mail from look
i mean i did i i looked into it deeply
in order to like mention duckbill
platypus at one of those points uh in
in the book and it's it's definitely not
that low but it's variable
it's very well not i don't think within
species of monogamous but between the
species
all right um are we on to
the question all right so i think we are
on to the question of
sam harris's podcast which came out
yesterday
now this is a slightly awkward topic
sam is a friend and the podcast he
released
yesterday with eric topel was
focused well it was focused on dark
darkhorse but it named
me specifically and it talked
extensively
about the issues surrounding kobe that
we've been
focused on for many months here
including the question
of ivermectin and the question of
uh vaccine hazards and vaccine
hesitancy and i must say there was a
certain amount of trepidation in
discovering that sam had released what
was obviously
a critical podcast of
of me and us i say that because
i know sam to be a
tremendously capable interlocutor
and i will say in my past i have
uh had a podcast on dark horse where
i talked to sam about free will
a topic on which i disagree with sam and
i believe he
uh he trounced me in that discussion
despite the fact that i suspect that i'm
actually right it took me a long time to
figure out
why it was that i was unable to make
my point compellingly it took me at
least a week to figure out where
um i thought the bodies were buried but
anyway the the point is sam is so good
at what he does
so smart and has in my opinion
um unassailable integrity that to find
that he was
uh dismayed enough with what has gone on
here on dark horse to take up the matter
in a concentrated form uh worried me
what would he find
and i must say that my reaction upon
listening all the way through it which i
did i listened all the way through it
and my sense is actually i'm not
angry at sam i'm not even
hurt and i'm actually weirdly heartened
that's just a kind of report
um for what it was like to listen
through this because
what i find is that there's very little
there
that actually lines up with what i or we
have actually said and so in some sense
if somebody
as capable as sam
is
i will try to say it delicately
struggling to make a
a serious critique of what we've been
doing that is a hopeful sign but it's
even more hopeful for the following
reason i know sam
would never intentionally straw man
uh another person and i know
that in particular he wouldn't do it to
a friend and in fact he in this podcast
uh goes to great lengths to say that he
does consider me a friend and
um and you know he says some
compassionate things
uh he also says some things about the
hazard of what we are doing here
to other people and this is an argument
i will i will take up in a second but
my basic point would be this when we
began talking about ivermectin
i said and i believe our first episode
in which we discussed it at any length
um that upon looking at the evidence in
this realm
i was struggling to find a polite way to
say
what the [ __ ] is going on here because
nothing in the context
of this uh set of claims
arguments or evidence seems to add up in
any straightforward way there is
something distorting the entire
discussion
and i have the sense that if sam will
look
at the podcast he's put out the claims
he has made
and then look at the critiques of those
claims and see how they actually line up
with what has been said here he will
realize that he
has found himself um somewhere
that he would not ordinarily find
himself and i think the upshot for any
honest broker of which sam is definitely
one
the the upshot would have to be well how
did i end up in this spot
right how did i end up and you know i
don't know how to say it more gently but
how did i end up
straw manning a friend on such an
important topic
um so go ahead since
many people won't have heard what we're
talking about what you're talking about
here um can i just provide one evidence
what one
one way in which um and it's all it's
all
i mean it's all in the abstract until
there's mention of particulars and then
it's you
um but one of one of the particular
things is right up front and i actually
have not
i've only listened to about three fifths
of it so far um but right up front
uh sam says uh sam claims there's a
bifurcation
and that's in fact his word the
bifurcation that he claims is that there
are people
who take kobits seriously who understand
what a scourge it is and how
dammable it is for humanity and that
those people embrace vaccines
and then the other side of the
bifurcation are the people who do not
take covert seriously who either think
it's a hoax or it's not worse than the
flu
or you know or whatever it is um
and that those people strangely are
concerned about vaccine safety but not
about covet
um safety now this is uh
the imagining that this is a that could
be a bifurcating
set is so so odd
honestly and like i i have somewhere to
say about that i know you weren't done
but i just wanted to provide
that as like even if it was just one
thing what is your position on
covid that's not going to be a binary
position
but then add to that what is the
solution that has no possibility of
being a bifurcating position
you know you cannot have a thing with a
decision on top of it
in which there's only two possible
outcomes that's just not logically that
doesn't make any sense
and um and of course it is utterly true
that since our very first live stream in
march of 2020
we have been banging the gong about the
seriousness of cove but in fact
um to the irritation of some number of
people who say we're taking it too
seriously you know wearing masks in
public before when anyone else was and
you know all of these things
and um and that the the claim right up
front
to set up you know his audience uh
as believing that you're either on this
side or not you've got stars on your
belly or you don't you're one of us or
you're one of them and you better hope
you're one of us because we're the
science people we're the reasonable
people
we're the democrats you know we're all
you're we're we're the tribal
affiliation
um and it's not you know that's not how
science works
yeah this this is actually uh so i we
are not going to do for one thing it's
only been out for
you know i think less than 24 hours but
at the very least it's been out for a
day at most
um the so we're not going to do an
exhaustive
i just wanted to mention what you keep
on saying straw manning and many people
won't have heard what
right so this is this is the the first
point i wanted to make just so and
again my point here is really that i
want sam to see that he has ended up
somewhere
that should cause all of us to be
scratching our heads because i think the
problem is
no matter what position you land on on
this
logical map none of this makes sense
there is something distorting our
ability
to see what our friends are saying
there's something that is distorting our
ability to understand what the evidence
actually implies
and that means that everybody is ending
up in some sort of
paradoxical landscape and you and i uh
in this case
we have been what i would describe as
covid hawks
from the beginning in fact uh you know
speaking of friends i have told joe
rogan twice on his program
that i thought he was
not concerned enough about covet right
um so the you know that's just a gentle
critique which is
this is a very dangerous disease the
hazard of it is not captured in the case
fatality rate the case fatality rate
is reasonably low but the amount of
damage and therefore probably the years
of people's lives that are lost to this
disease
is very high um that's anomalous it's
interesting but at the very least it
ought to have us be
quite careful and i will say this is an
interesting day to be having this
discussion
there are protests happening around the
world
against various measures some of those
measures are vaccine
passports so there are protests in my
understanding is
london paris sydney amsterdam
quebec milan there have been in greece i
don't know
in the uk i think so we've got lots of
people protesting now some of what i see
those protests being about
are quote unquote lockdowns which i've
never really liked as a term but
nonetheless
they're about some sort of civil liberty
incursions
and then others are about these
passports and there is a question about
if you had reasonable entities isn't
their third category though isn't it so
vaccine passport is a separate issue
from mandatory vaccination
well uh to be honest with you i don't
know enough about what's going on in the
rest of the world but the two things are
obviously connected if you're going to
be delivering
identical issues right but if you're
going to be delivering a coercive
penalty to people
for not being vaccinated and we will get
to why that is so preposterous no matter
what you think this is a preposterous
measure
um but in any case you and i have been
covet hawks right we have been
very careful about covid and initially
enthusiastic about the idea of vaccines
concerned about what we didn't know
about them going forward and then
increasingly alarmed by what we have
seen
in the data emerging about vaccine
hazards
but the point is we don't fit in either
of the categories right
as you say sam lays out uh two
categories one are people who are
cavalier about covid
and uh concerned about vaccine hazards
and the other is people who are
concerned about covid
and not so concerned about vaccines
there's no category for us because our
category is
yeah concerned about the vaccines and
concerned about covid
and at the very least having presented
that as his framework
and then never saying actually um dark
horse doesn't fit
in that framework at all right it also
doesn't fit in the framework
of uh the portrayal of this as a
political issue which
also comes up in this podcast right yes
there may be
more skepticism on the right of uh the
vaccine safety on the other hand we are
anything but from the right and
sam ought to know that because he along
with us has been portrayed again and
again
as somehow a right winger and it's not
true of any of us
well i will say at least um so far as
i've i've listened through it at this
point
um the numbers that they that
that harris and topple bring out are
about
republicans and their vaccination rates
both their intention to be vaccinated
before the vaccinations came out and
their actual vaccination rates
and democrats and increasingly i feel
like
don't we all know that democrats versus
republicans
doesn't capture a a rather large
percentage of americans there are a
whole lot of us i mean independents have
always been a real thing and you know a
substantial minority
um but i think um increasingly what has
happened in the last five years ish
a ton of people have uh have decided
that they that they can't abide
either of these parties anymore and so
those people
all of the independents are not captured
and i you know i think the number that
that sam mentions in there is that
only two percent i i hope i'm getting
this right i think what
the number was two percent but i think
what that two percent was referring to
was
only two percent of democrats are not
vaccinated now that's
a staggering number um and
uh that has to mean that they're um
that that the vast majority of people
who used to be democrats who are now
independents are part of the
um sort of the base going well actually
actually i know this is real i know
covet is a bad
thing and you and i can agree that
that's a bad thing but when you tell me
novel solution is the only correction to
bad thing and i say
let's talk about it if you come back at
me with if you don't agree to novel
solution you don't believe it's a bad
thing
that's a logical flaw on your end not on
mine and this is something i actually i
talked about
on episode 82 as well like i want to
know what the name for this logical
fallacy is
there's a bad thing out there yes there
is and there's only one solution of that
bad thing well let's talk about it ah if
you don't agree to my one solution then
you don't believe in the bad thing
no wrong yep
and uh this is closely
um i don't know what to say it is
similar in theme to eric's famous four
quadrant model which has now been
illustrated by several people where
one is forced into a box that does not
represent their position
but okay we've got a false dichotomy
you've really got
you know at least in theory uh four
different categories of people and only
two
are laid out in uh the podcast setup and
then
um we somehow end up uh falsely
aligned with those who are cavalier
about kobe which is anything
but our our position um
you know and it's not the only place
where we have uh a
narrowing of the discussion in sam's
podcast that
forces a an incoherent conclusion
there's also the question
about you know he portrays that some
people are vaccinated and
others are unprotected right now
in your in my case we are anything but
unprotected now
it could be that our understanding of
the evidence surrounding ivermectin is
somehow way off
now it'd be hard to imagine how one gets
there because actually there is a lot of
evidence not all of it is randomized
controlled trials
there are randomized controlled trials
but there's a tremendous amount of
evidence that suggests
this is a highly effective prophylactic
and actually it's interesting
as you go through uh the various edits
on the data
whether you're looking at the randomized
controlled trials or you're looking at
all of the trials
you get numbers in the range of 85
86 87 effective which is right up there
with vaccines and potentially better
than vaccines in light of the fact that
we don't see
the same uh degradation with respect to
the
protective nature of ivermectin against
variants
so um did you want to show this uh
paper um i want it to behave itself
first um you wanna you want me to show
both of them um yeah we could just
we could show both so these are uh
so this is uh these are both papers that
came out recently this is cone at all
in cell reports medicine i think is the
name of the
journal title although i'm not familiar
with it cell reports medicine yet
called longitudinal analysis shows
durable and broad immune memory after
sars cov2 infection
with persistent antibody responses and
memory bnt
cells so that's a pretty straightforward
title but in
in simpler english these authors i think
this was the eight month
one um they look at oh boy my
my computer is jumping around so i can't
actually look at it unless you want to
take off my screen for a minute suck so
i can take a look
um yeah it's eight months um they looked
at um
254 patients you can put my screen back
up here 254 patients
for eight months and that's just what
the longitudinal means there it's a time
time
longitude um and they found several
different ways in which those people
retain their immunity to covet
um having been exposed through the
disease not through vaccination
so that's one so so the upshot of this
is that the immunity that one gets the
natural immunity the natural
acquired immunity that one gets from
from
contracting the disease this is not
something you want but if you did
contract the disease
the immunity seems to be long lasting
and broad
yeah and you know is there any silver
lining at all to having had covid
um you know you really don't want it
long covet is is is terrible and
real and and we know people suffering
from it
and you definitely don't want it but you
know like with
the vast majority of other diseases out
there having had it does appear to
confer immunity
and then the second paper um in this
vein
is this ivanova so this one we should
warn
although we have serious critiques of
the peer review process
the second one is this is a pre-print
which means it hasn't gone through that
process
take that for what it's worth this was
posted in april 21st 2021
and it's still up as a pre-print this is
ivanova
at all called the screen um discrete
immune response signature to stars kobe
2 mrna vaccination
versus infection so unlike that first
one unlike
cohen at all which was simply trying to
assess whether or not there was
long-term immunity from having been
infected with covid
uh from having been infected with cysco
v2 this paper specifically looks at
what the differences in immune response
are to
having been vaccinated versus having
been exposed to to
sarcophagi ii the actual the actual
virus
and what they find is actually the
immunity conferred by having had the
disease is greater than the immunity
conferred by having had the vaccinations
it's
uh it is based on a much
broader immunological response yeah um
it is also likely to be more durable
which is uh
consistent with the other paper that you
showed anyway i would also point out
that this is something that we here on
dark horse have predicted
again and again right simply looking at
the narrowness
of the mechanism of induced immunity by
the vaccines it is
very narrowly targeted and so what we
have said
and by the way the cdc uses
as their justification for attempting to
get people who have
already had covet uh to get them
vaccinated
is that we don't know how long their
immunity will last now that's a nonsense
justification even if it was true that
we simply don't know the answer is at
the point that we see that immunity
beginning to decay
then we could do it right but and we you
know was it was it last week or a week
before that pfizer
given the evidence coming out of israel
that uh
immunity from post-vaccination was
lapsing
in the face of delta about six months
post-vaccination
and that pfizer was i i don't know maybe
they've pulled this back because i
haven't seen anything about this in the
last few days
but fizer was saying actually you're
gonna need boosters every six months
so you know the cohen at all papers
suggests and they just stopped it eight
months it's not like they said immunity
drops at eight months they said
actual exposure to stars kobe 2 having
had go but gives you longitudinal
immunity
at least eight months and meanwhile some
signals from
the mrna vaccines are suggesting that
they are shorter lived than that
um right so with respect to uh
to sam's podcast i would just simply
point out that any analysis that forces
us
into a dichotomy of the vaccinated and
the unprotected
is inherently wrong we unfortunately
have a large number of people
who have had covid and apparently have
immunity so if you believed that there
was no
adverse event signal that was meaningful
in the vaccines you might argue well
there's no cost to vaccinating them
but that is not the case nobody has
established that that signal that is
very obviously in the various data
is meaningless it could be meaningless
but the burden is on those who believe
it is meaningless to
show that the anomalously large signal
doesn't mean anything and until you do
it makes sense to take all of those
people who haven't
uh who have had covid and eliminate the
hazard that there is some
negative side effect of these vaccines
to which they for which they would get
no benefit
so at the very least you have those two
categories you have people
whose immunity came from the disease who
are not unprotected
and are not vaccinated and raise
substantial questions with respect to
anything like a vaccine passport i would
point out
right these people should have an
exemption but the other thing is
for people you know and it's not easy to
get ivermect in the united states as far
as i know it's
all but impossible in canada and i can't
speak to the rest of the world but
what i can say is for those of us who
have decided that
actually that adverse event signal is
scary
that the variance and the drop-off in
immunity
is troubling and have used this
alternative
method i think the burden is on anybody
who believes that this is not
highly effective to explain why it is
that
you know a repeated demonstration that
we have something like 86
87 protection uh is not sufficient
right so um all right
in terms of again my point here is i
think
if sam looks at
the claims that were made in his podcast
and then he looks at the analyses of
that podcast and i know he's getting a
lot of
pushback from various quadrants
i will say thread emerged last night
um zach do you want to show that twitter
thread
okay uh this is a thread by
alexandros morenos i should say
i have never met alexandros have you
ever met alexandros
we have not met alexandros i will say he
is engaged in a
project that he calls better skeptics
which makes me nervous because what he's
been doing
is uh incentivizing people to find
errors in our podcasts and then he has a
group of referees who are looking into
them and i'm very concerned
that at the level of going through
people's transcripts and finding errors
there's a hazard but i'm also encouraged
that he is attempting to do the job well
which would involve
calibrating any errors
found and weighting them correctly
following through to see what their
logical implication might be
let me just say that um i i think he
invoked this
um idea that that we and this podcast
needs better skeptics in
in the wake of the colette article by
berlin skindigan from a couple weeks ago
and um i i just wholeheartedly agree
with this we we
all all of us need better skeptics no
matter how good our skeptics are
um but with first uh that piece in
colette two weeks ago and now this
podcast yesterday
um i feel it even more intently that you
know we really we
really 100 need people who are
going to be honorable and scientific
rather than obscuring their actual
perverse incentives and political
in assessing what it is that we are
doing yes
uh oddly i'm not sure if it's true or
not but um i think he may be quoting you
that the term better skeptics may have
been borrowed from something you said on
a stream but in any case uh
okay it's all we could just keep
pointing at each other fold it in on it
but anyways my basic point is i am uh
cautiously encouraged
that um that alexandros and his team
are going to overcome the obstacles to
this kind of analysis which
involve basically calibrating and
waiting uh the various conclusions
and then figuring out how to compare
them to uh to other things but anyway we
can talk more about that some other time
in any case here um alexandros has done
a thread in which he goes through sam's
podcast from yesterday
and uh he found many of the critiques
that i would make he found a few that i
didn't know to make
so he checks into some claims and
actually i learned one thing about
us from his thread which i found
encouraging that
i would learn something about myself uh
what he points to in this
thread is he says that you and i
actually have
a bias in the direction of caution
which he takes from several things that
we have oh yeah yeah you know
i saw that wow that's you know that's
exactly what
the reputation of your grandfather was
this is exactly my
thought now it's like we are so
interested in risk and so interested
in like getting rid of all the
unnecessary risks so that serendipity
can allow us to go places but
i would say he's he's right in one way i
think he's right in one way anyway he
points to are two things he points to
the fact
that you and i have a you know it's
informal but a policy where if one of us
is sick or thinks they're getting
sick we sleep separately which
epidemiologically
obviously makes sense right it's the
it's the kind thing to do
um and then the other thing is that we
are not eating fish from the pacific
after the fukushima incident which may
sound wild-eyed and crazy
of course that is the result of the fact
that after the fukushima accident
fish were tested from the pacific and
the results were alarming
right and this is i have not looked at
this since
it's been a while the accident was in
2011 and the
long time it wasn't too long after but
what what these samples showed
were then and so basically there are two
isotopes that you would be
particularly concerned about one of them
is cesium the other one is strontium
one is a muscle seeker the other is a
bone seeker and these things
these isotopes cause cancer because the
radioactive decay
and it's actually it's not just the
radiations the fact that you have a
radioactive
particle basically a piece of dust
radiating the tissue
around it but the basic point was in
salmon
it was a very high percentage of fish my
recollection was it was something like
half of the animal sampled
had cesium from fukushima in their
tissues and strontium wasn't tested so
we it's not like we can say any of the
fish were free of
of radioactive isotopes and in tuna the
number was something like 100
and the reason was apparently that
ecologically the tuna
were uh spending their youth in places
that were
contaminated um in any case well and
they're higher up the food chain
well they're both they're both high up
the food chain you're right some tuna
big real big tuna are
of the food chain but in any case the
point is yes
we are cautious about certain things why
are we cautious because actually
as you point out with my grandfather
harry was very cautious about hazards
that could be managed but he was also
the guy who hiked up mount whitney with
me and when it was time to come back
down we slid down a glacier on trash
bags that he had
packed for the purpose so anyway we're
the cautious people who took our
children to the amazon and like actually
to the amazon not the
not the fancy easy to get to and i know
it doesn't feel easy but you know not
the place that most green goes go when
they think they're in the amazon but we
actually took them there once
you know once we felt that they were old
enough to well actually be able to
um afford to be vaccinated against
yellow fever and all the other things
that one needs to be vaccinated against
to be safe there
and um and you there are risks but you
get rid of the risks that you can
yes what are you laughing i'm laughing
at the idea of a fancy amazon
because frankly i find the whole thing
fancy i really do yeah but you know i
mean
so you know what i mean and actually
probably most most viewers and listeners
don't but the vast majority you know and
i've talked to people who think that
they experience the amazon and
you know those of us who are actually
tropical biologists listen to what they
report
and where they are where they were and
what just outside of the
resort and maybe they didn't call it a
resort but what that looked like and
um you know there's a lot of ways to get
people into things that feel like
they're the real deal
and are actually some disney fight
version of it um i would put it i would
put it
a different way um i would say that the
sensitivity of tropical forest
to disruption is immense and that
basically
the edges are thoroughly compromised
virtually everywhere and so the problem
is that when
one wants to it's very easy to end up
with an emptied forest or a forest in
which
um certain creatures have been curated
it's very difficult to get to a place
and you know even the place that we go
has been compromised by you know
fans from the outside as you know i
never published this but my very
first research in grad school ended up
being on um
the effects of a so-called eco-tourist
lodge having introduced a
slightly bigger and more charismatic
poison dart frog to the area because the
one that was actually native there
wasn't quite big enough for the tourists
to see easily and of course the bigger
slightly more charismatic poison dart
frog
drove the original native one completely
locally extinct
you know as you would predict so you
know i do i do have a bias
towards thinking you know whenever i see
development
that is aimed at appealing
to the aesthetics of northerners of
gringos
um that pretty much every time i've then
gone down into that rabbit hole and
investigated what they're doing
the ways that they appeal to the
aesthetics and the desire for comfort of
those of us who don't live there
tends to be destructive of the actual
environment yeah
i mean it's a it's a general tourism
problem extended to
to forest anyway we're sort of uh far
afield here
um maybe to close this out i want to
point out a couple things
um i think that in light of
uh what sam released and in light of the
um many valid critiques that have been
leveled
and can be leveled against it that there
has to be
this is an invitation to a conversation
and i think the
theme of the conversation has to be um
what the [ __ ] is going on here right
because what the [ __ ] is going on here
is the only
way to interpret um the fact that we all
end up in
these strange categories so
you know among the things that need to
be i think explained
sam who's generally very careful in his
podcast
is searching it's clear that he is
earnestly searching for an explanation
as to why um
people who appear to be credible doctors
i think he's specifically pointing to dr
corey who showed up with me on joe
rogan's program
could possibly be so um
mistaken that could possibly be on the
wrong side of this and he's
grasping for an explanation and it's
obvious he's not accusing anybody of
being schizophrenic but this is what he
reaches for he says
you know of course they're you know and
it's like really is that
is that where he's like he's so this is
not in a part that i've listened to yet
but he's like appealing to the base rate
of schizophrenia in the population and
imagining that some that explains some
of what we're seeing
i look i think what he's really doing is
he's looking for a proof of concept that
something could explain why a doctor
would be so far off the mark and so
clearly so and the answer is the doctor
isn't so far off the mark and it is not
that he is clearly so the problem is
that this landscape is so confusing that
if you start with the conclusion
that vaccines are safe they are the only
way forward
and anybody who says otherwise is
obviously
deeply confused and then you try to
explain how you know an
icu doctor is so deeply confused with
the answer is
i don't know you need some exotic
explanation um
likewise eric topple portrays
robert malone as not the inventor of
uh mrna vaccine technology which is
clearly not the case this has been
looked into there are
uh there are publications and there are
uh
patents that clearly indicate that he is
where he said he was
so i think we need to close this out but
the basic point is the podcast that was
released
um proceeds from
the argument that nobody who is
concerned alarmed about the vaccine
hazards or
very enthusiastic about the possibility
that repurposed drugs could be highly
effective at preventing
covid or could be useful
in driving the pathogen to extinction
could possibly be right
and on the discovery that those claims
aren't
correct that the the confusion um
is born of some other um other cause the
right thing to do is to have a
conversation and i would like to
have that conversation with you sam
privately publicly whatever you think
uh the right way to do it is but it
seems like the right way to go
um so you want you want to close that
out
and so this is not directly about about
that
but i did want to point out two
bmj british medical journal opinion
pieces that have been published in the
last couple of months
that just speak to the fact that there
are actually a large number of people
medical professionals who are even
willing to speak publicly
and that of course doesn't address the
very very very many number of people
uh who are are not able to speak
up for whatever reason so here we have
for instance
zach if you will show my screen here uh
from june 8 2021
why we petitioned the fda to refrain
from fully approving any coven 19
vaccine this year
uh and it begins we are part of a group
of clinicians scientists and patient
advocates who have lodged a formal
citizen petition with the us fda
asking the agency to delay any
consideration of a full approval of a
copenhagen vaccine
and this is this is related to the
podcast from yesterday only in that
i believe topple specifically says you
know of course people are scared it's
only
got an eua it's only got an emergency
use authorization why won't the fda do
what it needs to do
well there are a number of people in
the health professions who are saying um
actually and here it is our petition
doesn't argue that risks outweigh
benefits
or that benefits outweigh risks rather
we focus on methods and processes
outlining the many remaining unknowns
about safety and effectiveness
and suggest the kinds of studies needed
to address the open questions
so this sounds like both caution
and science to me and then there is a
similar one from may 7th also in bmj
opinion british medical journal opinion
titled covert vaccines for children
should not get emergency use
authorization
and so this is um a different it's a
smaller group of people but they are
saying
um you know based on very similar
arguments
that we don't know enough yet and that
effectively this is not their language
but
the children should not be the guinea
pigs yeah not only not the guinea pigs
but
um the fact that kids appear to tolerate
covet extremely well
uh and have apparent risk from the
vaccines suggests that we have an
obligation to uh to exclude them
from the hazard if it doesn't come to
their benefit otherwise it becomes a
transfer
of health from the young to the old and
a rational civilization
wouldn't do that actually i did want to
make one other suggestion uh something
that has increasingly bothered me and
this
showed up in the sam's podcast but it
didn't start there it's almost
ubiquitous
in the the battle over the evidence here
it has to do with the claim
that the other side is killing people
right now my sense is this is actually
logically a very simple issue
you and i wouldn't be doing what we are
doing
if we thought that the arguments we were
making were liable to
harm more people than they helped now
it's not as simple a calculation as how
many lives saved because as we just
pointed out
i at least and i assume you would uh
argue to protect children even at
an increased number of lost lives
amongst uh the elderly
um but nonetheless there's some basic
calculation
that we ought to all agree on that we're
trying to minimize harm in some way that
is weighted towards
you know the quality of lives lost or
however one would rationally do it
so that means that we are looking at the
evidence and we
are doing what it seems is
most likely to minimize the harm
is it guaranteed to no and we've talked
about that it's not
a very pleasant position to be in that
when you air your position publicly that
you know it will have consequences
uh for people's lives that certain
number of people will um
perhaps die because of what you're
saying on the other hand
i would never portray
sam or yuri or claire
as killing people i know that they're
motivated by a desire to
to get the evidence properly understood
to minimize the hazard to people we just
disagree over what the evidence suggests
and so i guess my point is it's like a
mathematical equation
right if everybody is motivated
by looking at the evidence and trying to
minimize harm to humanity
then that part cancels out from both
sides of the equation and what we're
left with is a disagreement over what
the evidence implies the best way
forward
is why can't we have that argument
without
one side portraying portraying the other
as
um either indifferent to harm or as eric
topel said of me yesterday he called me
predatory
yeah right as if that makes any sense at
all
topple wasn't careful in the way that
that sam was
at all and there was just a ton of
falsehood there out of his mouth but um
i do think that i have said here um on
previous episodes
at least once i think um that if for
instance youtube is going to have a
policy
by which you cannot speak the you know
you cannot say
the name of the drug that we should call
that you know that we might call
voldemort
um that they that
they are actually the ones with blood on
their hands and so i have said that
about the entities um at least once at
least with regard to youtube
um and i'm not i'm sure i've thought it
i'm not sure i've said it about
um the other entities that might be
obscuring
uh some of you know the the benefits of
ivermectin for instance
um but but never about individuals
so that's so that's the comparison
you're making but i just wanted to be
clear that
um you know there i do think that there
ultimately
will be there's there's blood um
but it's it's in the sort of
metaphorical hands of entities
of you know entities that don't actually
have hands that's you know that's part
of how it works that's right
it means a lot to happen if you you know
if you capture
a regulatory body and
you corrupt it so that it can't monitor
a hazard or something like that yeah
that's obviously a different matter
us out here in the public trying to
navigate a comp a confusing
uh set of evidence is a whole different
matter
also a whole different matter i'm
getting
you know you and i have predicted that
the unvaccinated will be blamed
for uh the variance and for the upsurge
in kovid that is certain to come
with uh the donning of the northern
winter despite predictions from you know
long before covid
that uh mass vaccination during a
pandemic will create selective pressure
for new variants
right and so i think the point is look i
wouldn't
blame the vaccinated even though there's
an argument to be made that vaccination
is playing a key role in the generation
of variants and i don't want to see the
unvaccinated blamed especially
in light of the fact that the
unvaccinated are several different
categories some of which
are pretty likely to be blameless
right so you know those who have had
covid and are unvaccinated
are not guilty in any conceivable way
right likewise if iramectin actually
works the way the evidence seems to
suggest it does
people who have gone out of their way to
protect themselves in this alternative
form
are actually much less likely to be
contributing but at the very worst what
you have
is a complex analysis in which do the
unvaccinated
who have not had covid and aren't on
ivermectin do they play a role
in the ongoing pandemic of course they
do do the vaccinated play a role
of course they do right these things are
part of
a complex system and the right way
to analyze it is to exclude blame
and try to understand what's taking
place and what might best be done
in order to get control of the pandemic
let me just show this paper actually i
haven't spent a lot of time with it
yet but um it's from 2015. it has
nothing to do with covet at all
read at all published in
uh plos biology imperfect vaccination
can enhance the transmission of highly
virulent pathogens
uh and the last sentence of the abstract
reads our data show that anti-disease
vaccines that do not prevent
transmission
can create conditions that promote the
emergence of pathogen strains that cause
more severe disease and unvaccinated
hosts
it's very much in keeping with what
we've been talking about for months
it's frankly it's not a stretch it's not
it's not a leap to think this you know
all you have to do is think a little bit
evolutionarily to imagine that this
would be
um likely and here we have a paper from
six years ago saying
you know be aware be aware and this you
know again imperfect
vaccination is just a term of art here
meaning that it doesn't 100 percent
prevent transmission and indeed we don't
i i don't think that we yet have
evidence
that these vaccines are preventing
transmission at at all
are they i mean like i'm not sure about
that
what they seem to be doing most of their
effectiveness seems to be about reducing
the degree of disease that people who do
end up getting it having
but but i'm not i'm not positive with
the evidence almost certainly they're
going to reduce
the amount of transmission but the
problem is
that they constitute an inadvertent gain
of function experiment
right you are collect you're creating a
kind of hazard that the virus then
evolves past and um that
is unavoidable in the circumstance what
is inexcusable
is that we are not paying attention to
the signs that
we might be doing something wrong in
this regard what we are doing instead
is rationalizing away the signal that
this might be having
an adverse consequence and that uh
really is
troubling and i i guess that it does
raise one final point
i also felt in sam's podcast that it was
ungenerous especially in light of the
fact that they spent time
talking about the lab leak and the fact
that
civilization at large changed its tune
on this
what they did not point out was that
like on many issues surrounding kovid
we have been early on this and we have
been right and in
fact eric topel did not acknowledge that
he has been wrong until very recently in
fact he took jon stewart to task
for that's really recent it's it's very
recent
um the fact that he also appears to have
a relationship with christian
anderson raises a question about whether
or not he's in fact
viewing that issue objectively but
nonetheless what i would say
is and i tried to say this at the
beginning of my podcast with pierre
corey
i tried to say look if you have somebody
who has gone against the grain and
against the social pressure
right and said look no the evidence
suggests this thing and then suffered
you know something like a year of being
stigmatized
for saying such a thing and then they
turn out to be right my sense is that
gives you a certain budget
right and i think the point is that
budget
means that at the point that i say
something or you say
something that amounts to actually the
conventional narrative
is dangerously off it doesn't make us
right but it means leaping to the idea
that we've somehow missed the boat
lost our minds the question is well is
this going to be another one of those
cases
where we turn out to be right down the
road
right and all of the stigma on the way
there is just simply
misdirected um all right maybe now we
are there what do you think
sure um should we talk about sleep let's
talk about sleep let's talk about sleep
let's just start
uh so this is uh sleep is chapter six of
of our forthcoming book as i said at the
top of the hour
and um it's gonna be a short excerpt
today just two pages
from the middle of the chapter so in the
beginning of the chapter we walk through
a little bit about what sleep is and
whether or not we think
um aliens if they landed on the planet
would recognize what we do for
a third of our lives i'm not going to
give that away i'm just going to jump
right into the section
called dreams and hallucinations
you'll remember this moment in the
darkest quietest moment of some night
long ago
hours after we had both been asleep
heather sat up looked at brett and said
do you seriously intend to leave these
car parts on the bed
brett's answer i think so yes did not
ease tensions any
furthermore the fact that there were of
course no car parts anywhere near the
bed would not be admitted as evidence in
this discussion
it wasn't the first time that heather
had said something while deeply asleep
that was impossible to engage using the
normal rules
when brett responded to heather's sleep
talk the tone generally decayed quickly
there was it seemed no reasoning with
either of us without having any
consciousness of these episodes heather
somehow
knew later went awake and being told
about them what brett was supposed to do
don't engage me let me have both sides
of the conversation it will be over soon
enough
seeing things that aren't there hearing
sounds that were never made believing
things that are not true yet being
certain of them
being unable to control one's movements
having conversations with people who
don't exist
as it turns out a list of symptoms of a
person with schizophrenia has a
suspicious overlap with a person asleep
and dreaming
all of us enter this state every night
even though not everyone reaches out
through that state and talks in their
sleep
we do not regularly draw this parallel
because our dream state usually comes
with paralysis and amnesia
any confrontations with reality are
blissfully hidden from us by the time we
get to our morning coffee
how surprising then that organisms that
do not appear to have had our best
interests in mind
such as psilocybe mushrooms and peyote
cactus seem to have accessed these very
same tendencies to explain this we need
to take a step back
organisms including us and other animals
plus plants and fungi
do not generally want to be eaten fruit
nectar and milk are as we discussed in
the previous chapter
exceptions to this rule but in general
organisms put a lot of work into
discouraging the consumption of their
body parts
structural barriers are one method
cactus spines porcupine coils turtle
shells
another is poison but it is often too
crude to be maximally effective
if a deer dies after eating foxglove the
deer will be replaced by another deer
that knows nothing of the plant's poison
on the other hand
if a deer expands its dietary repertoire
to include psilocybe mushrooms and
spends the rest of the day having a
temporary psychotic break
it would may well look elsewhere for its
next meal having been educated and
perhaps terrorized
rather than killed secondary compound is
a loosely defined botanical term for a
substance that is not functional within
the organism that produces it
rather it is intended to interact with
pathways and other creatures often in a
hostile way
the irritants in poison ivy are an
obvious deterrent to herbivores eating
those leaves
similarly potatoes in the other
nightshades contain endogenous
pesticides a class of compounds known as
glycoalkaloids
that are highly toxic to humans in
contrast to those pure poisons and
irritants consider these secondary
compounds
capsaicin the molecule that creates the
burning sensation when we eat chili
peppers
generally dissuades mammals from eating
seeds that are intended for birds which
do not have the receptors to sense the
heat
and caffeine which disincentivizes
herbivores from eating caffeinated seeds
at high concentrations
may also be a kind of pharmacological
social engineering on the part of the
plants
when bees are given sugar rewards that
contain caffeine their spatial memory
improve
improves threefold the caffeinated
nectar of both citrus
and coffee flowers may well be priming
their pollinators the bees to remember
them and to come back for more
from suicide mushrooms and ergot fungi
to peyote cactus and the botanical brew
in ayahuasca
to salvia and sonoran desert toads there
are fungi plants and animals that have
produced secondary compounds that
interact with our physiology in ways
that mirror dream states
call them hallucinogens or psychedelics
or entheogens their effect on us can be
narrative and elucidating
we live our days connected by dreams
lest we wake up each morning imagining
that we are brand new beings our dreams
give us context and allow us to grow
between days
we are conscious during the day and
unconscious in the first part of the
night during non-rem sleep
once rem picks up in the second half of
each night our consciousness is borrowed
our bodies taken safely offline
paralyzed and our conscious minds create
fiction strange
hypothetical and extravagant sometimes
they are even true a vast arrays of cult
a vast array of cultures have some
tradition in which hallucinogenic states
are intentionally triggered and some are
all of their members
humans being human it is not surprising
to find that many cultures have borrowed
secondary compounds that trigger
terrifying waking dreams
and have turned what might have been a
bad trip into an important tool for
human consciousness expansion
more on this in chapter 12. just as many
cultures have appropriated the
hallucinogenic secondary compounds of
plants and fungus to expand the
consciousness of their members
many also have sleep rituals from the
simple to the elaborate by which
individuals prepare for the nightly
slumbers
even some of our closest relatives
engage in rituals in advance of sleep
and the next section tells of us
discovering some in some
spider monkeys in guatemala
pretty exciting i'm actually quite
interested to hear
uh what the world will make of the set
of hypotheses
when it engages them it's uh it's
something i've long wanted to bring into
the world and i guess we're finally
gonna find out
whether uh um whether people are ready
for it
but uh um anyway uh
well where do you what do you think we
should talk about here yeah i mean
there's there's a lot to say yeah
there's a lot to say actually
zach did you just get an email from me i
wanted to show this uh
years after we started talking about um
these hypotheses
uh i ran into this cartoon it's an xkcd
cartoon um you'll have to make a bit
bigger i think for most people
people including people on mobile who
might want to see it
um so it starts out with uh
a guy he's just awakened from a dream
there are people repelling from
zeppelin there's a nuclear explosion
going on near
a major city
he runs down the stairs
uh he goes to the breakfast table to
talk to his significant other as the
whole thing
evaporates and he's left with almost
nothing he could possibly describe
and she appears to be nonplussed right
and the uh hidden caption
uh to the thing is every damn morning
that's the title actually
oh it's every day morning yeah um anyway
so yes this idea that our dreams are
actually
um built to be hidden from our conscious
minds in a certain way
and then you know it wasn't in the piece
that you
read but the fact that some dreams
aren't
so dreams aren't what aren't deliberate
or not adaptively hidden
there seem to be some dreams that just
have their message right there
emblazoned on them is that what you mean
well what i mean is there's a difference
between the dream that you can't
remember
and the dream that you can struggle to
remember something of and the dream
that to my way of thinking is actually
handed across the consciousness barrier
because its purpose is actually for your
consciousness to see it which feel very
different and i think these are all
disrupted by
our terrible relationship with alarm
clocks
which basically interrupt our dream
cycles arbitrarily alarm clocks
and other intrusions in the soundscape
and also light
and we'll talk a little bit about light
here but yeah right yeah but for those
of us
um who sometimes have the experience of
solving a difficult problem in our sleep
right it's very often one of these
things where you awake with a solution
that you're keenly aware of
well and so i mean you you say that
speaking specifically of mental or
intellectual problems right
um i think i think probably everyone has
everyone has solved problems in their
sleep whether or not they recognize it
as such so there are you know there are
physical problems that can be solved if
you're like a craftsman if you're trying
to figure out how to you know make a
particular joint or something
um but also the one that is probably the
most ubiquitous and perhaps the most
ancient of at least
these types that we've sort of
categorized here um
are just you know how how to get your
body to do a thing
and in the modern world that might be
you know skateboarding or
rock climbing or forehand frisbee or you
know whatever it is
but you know you work at it you work out
you work at it at some point you get you
know you either walk away
calm or not and
the next time you try it if you have had
time to sleep between now and then
you're almost always better at it
right and the the distinction yeah i
mean
as people who uh know the podcast well
or people who
uh will read in the book um
obviously all that dream stuff has to
pay
its way right not every dream does but
on average it all has to pay its way
because it's very expensive
um so the question is which so expense
it's metabolically expensive because the
brain
is uh by far the most expensive organ to
run in the body and when it's doing all
this extra stuff
even if it's got body offline actually
muscle muscles are cheaper to run
um in in aggregate than the brain is
yeah the brain is just
a super expensive run you can also you
know
you can dormantize it and so choosing to
make it active
about narratives that aren't real and on
all of that is something adaptation has
done to us for a reason
what the reason isn't so obvious but
that there's a reason or that there has
to be
is clear enough but the point is
yes we have all probably most of what we
do in dreams is at least attempt to
solve problems and
we will all have solved problems and in
general those dreams that you can't
remember are presumably about solving
uh problems that you uh you know at some
level that is not conscious
um but yeah the dreams i was talking
about the ones that seem to get handed
across the consciousness barrier
are ones you know in my experience it's
been like there's some
object that you're trying to fix and you
can't figure out
why it's not working and then you wake
up with the solution to it
it's clear that that work was done by
your sleeping self
but it's also clear that your your
unconscious mind isn't in a position to
operationalize it
right yeah so it's yeah it's a pretty
fascinating
i do still wonder about those car parts
though
um yes well i mean you know i i hadn't
thought it through
but yeah i mean they had to go somewhere
i guess yeah you do always
threaten to store things on my side of
the bed since that incident
yeah is that just me yeah no one else
threatens to store things on my side of
the bed
right no i just thought it was
symmetrical i thought you know i i do
threaten
new objects that have no place i think
if i do that it's following your lead oh
is that right yes
oh god yes i've created a monster yeah
yeah he wants to store things on my side
of the bed yeah apparently
um okay more more
from this or um i mean i don't know i'm
i'm pretty happy with it but all right
uh let us
then so i'm just going to read as as we
mentioned last week
most of the chapters in the book have at
the very end um
the corrective lens um and so just the
last corrective lens from the sleep
chapter is this
this advice that we are giving most of
these are at the individual level this
is one for the societal level
restrict outdoor blue spectrum light at
the societal level particularly lights
that shine upward and outward at all
hours of the night
nighttime darkness is healthy 24 hour
light is not and is even implicated in
higher rates of disease
furthermore humans deserve a night sky a
sky full of possibilities sometimes of
clouds often the moon
occasionally planets nearly always stars
in the milky way in which we live
besides sleep which we need what else
might we lose when we disappear our own
night sky and we don't know the answer
to that
right we will lose we potentially lose a
lot
and in light of that in light of that
there's a review paper out this year um
called non-visual effects of indoor
light environment on humans a review so
this isn't this is
very very restrictive you know it's not
about visual effects it's not about the
effects of outdoor stuff
um but it's a review of the um
extant evidence which concludes a few
things
and really they aren't going to be
surprising but um
but it's it's all nicely in in this one
paper now
they find um from the review of the
literature that at night
uh well that first of all let me just
define a few terms they've got
illuminance
as one of their terms which is just um i
mean it's just basically brightness
luminous flux per unit as measured in
either foot candles or lux
so illuminance and then cct which is the
correlated color temperature
which is basically a measure of
temperature which is to say the higher
cct the bluer and cooler
the light is and the lower the cct the
warmer and yellower the light is and so
um in advance of us going through the
evidence
um daytime light tends to be blue and
um end of day and fire lights tend to be
you know warmer cct
lower cct and yellow or redder
okay so at night both high luminance
brighter and high cct that is cooler
bluer light
are positively correlated with the
suppression of melatonin
which i think many of us knew that but
um there is there's basically nothing
going in the opposite direction there
um furthermore um exposure to both blue
light and high cct light
basically the same thing not quite you
know different researchers using
slightly different standards and
measures at night exposure to the to
blue knight blue light and cool light at
night
induce a delayed phase shift which is
also consistent with
a reduction in melatonin
so um basically your sleep is going to
be disrupted
um you know but it's not you know
in in almost none of these cases can you
just say ah you know high cct light bad
blue light bad
no you know during the day especially in
the mornings
the more exposed we are to blue light
and i think i mentioned this last week
although maybe
i failed to but there's a different
piece of research that shows that
the earlier in the mornings you tend to
be exposed
to bright light to outdoor light to
cooler light um
that correlates with lower bmi like you
know
obesity tends not to to to thrive as
well among people
who are getting out into bright outdoor
light early in the mornings
um so high cct again the bluer light
stimulates positive mood
and high illuminance during the daytime
is positively correlated with subjective
alertness so you know you're more awake
there's also a bunch of mood stuff the
mood stuff is a little
dicier so i didn't include it here um
and then one of the papers that they
cite
from 2013 is
that after you know after millennia
maybe more than millennia
of sort of folk folk tales and
cultural stories about the moon
influencing
um influencing all sorts of things
influencing mood and fertility and
behavior
and you know all of these things there's
a paper from 2013
that finds that the lunar cycle does
indeed influence human sleep
and they actually did this um they went
and collected data
that had been collected from a sleep lab
so afterwards people who actually aren't
even affected by the light from the moon
it's actually in the like with they've
picked up enough information about what
the
lunar cycle is that even while the moon
is not impacting them directly it's
still affecting their sleep
yeah so what they have is um
uh and suff electroencephalogram
delta activity during nrem sleep so eeg
delta activity during non-rem sleep
which is an indicator of deep sleep
decreases by 30 percent during the full
moon
time to fall asleep increases by five
minutes not a lot um
but the eeg assessed total sleep
duration is also reduced by 20 minutes
during the full moon without you know
for people who were sleeping
inside in a sleep lab without any you
know
without this being on the table about
something that they were being
asked to think about it's interesting
because people are so disconnected from
the lunar cycle now that it's hard for
me to
you know that's some signal is so strong
that it's getting through the fact that
if you ask most people on most days
where we are in the lunar cycle they
have no idea
right and um i mean i think this is this
is beautiful because it's uh it's a full
moon right now
today is the full moon and uh it's you
know especially in the northern summer
at least in in the part of the world
where we live we're going to have a
clear blue sky
and i was i was lucky enough to be out
on the water very early this morning
um and you know bright
bright blue illuminance you know
high high illuminance bright high cct
light early in the morning and then to
be able to go back out at night and see
the full moon rising and um
yeah it's gonna take a little longer to
fall asleep maybe for you know for
for the whole planet during during a
full moon according to this research
and your sleep duration is going to be
reduced by a bit and
um what what this paper didn't try to
look at um but what
i predict is true is that there are also
going to be seasonal differences right
and so
you know whereas we have these
expectations in modern in weird
countries
that you know you start work at eight or
you you go to class at eight
and that happens you know the farther
away from the equator you are the less
sense that makes physiologically
across the entire year you know 8 a.m
here in in september when classes start
um it's very very bright out and in
december it's still dark out
and you know being expected to to get up
with the same enthusiasm and alertness
and ability to do calculus or whatever
it is
you know you're going to uh if you've
been
you've been raised in part by the
photons from the sun
as opposed to by you know your mom
telling you have to get out of bed
and uh and your alarm clock uh of course
you're not going to be equally capable
of course not yeah in in some sense
um i think i think we made the point uh
on dark horse
several weeks ago that there is a
distinction between biological time
and laboratory time and it's not that
laboratory time
doesn't exist it's not that somebody
made it up right
laboratory time exists and you can
measure it but the idea
that what we're going to do is build
mechanical clocks
and and align ourselves with them align
our behavior with them
that's not how it works and you know as
soon as you
break your cycle just you know even
somebody who lives by
clocks if you go backpacking right
suddenly you find yourself not so eager
to stay up to 11
right you know it's like oh the sun sets
unless it's
late june and you're on vancouver island
right right you're very far north yeah
but the point is you know
you tend to get up very easily you don't
need an alarm clock in the morning and
you don't need somebody to tell you hey
it's getting really late you need to go
to bed
because it just it resets very very
quickly
um now you know the problem is it trades
off two things your
your personal cycle and how it
interfaces with
uh you know the the celestial
motions of various objects um
is at odds with your ability to say i
will meet you at this place at that time
right or we will engage in this activity
in this location
you know on this day and this time we
have to be able to do that because
that's the way civilization works but to
imagine that we are not borrowing from a
much more natural
intuitive and ancient interaction with
time
is is just it's an error yeah
and you know you see you begin to see in
a way that i don't feel like i was
seeing
signage at parks and such in the 70s and
80s when we were growing up
um you know some places now say open you
know dawn to dusk this sort of thing um
but then
i was at a i was at a park i hadn't been
at um before
last week and it was it was weird it was
like open
8 a.m through dusk it's like why and i
was
you know i again was showing up to some
new place to paddle paddleboard on some
new river
um and i was there at seven and it was
it had been the sun had risen an
hour and a half earlier and i was there
an hour before the park opened i just
thought you know why
like what what's to what end is this
park
closed uh until 8 a.m even though
it being open 8 a.m in the winter you
know to the degree that it's about
safety
and and you know not being policed um
when it's dark out
well you know just just make it dawn to
dusk then
yeah i mean i agree with you that that's
you know the good thing about a don and
dusk rule is that
you can operationalize it because
everybody can figure out whether it's
you know after dawn or past dusk
um the problem is probably
an enforcement issue unfortunately right
but in the in this particular case
they had one end that was a clock a you
know
a lab time in your formulation and one
that was an astronomical time
and um yeah i just it seemed it seemed a
little random
to choose one you know one is a lab time
and one is an astronomical time yeah
yeah but you're also right that as you
get closer to the equator
these things become you know if you're
really close to the equator they become
so
regular that you actually um do it six
to six you know like that's
right and exactly and it doesn't it
doesn't wobble
at the equator but um the farther north
or south you are the farther away from
the equator you are at the more
variation it's going to be and
like i said i think um you know now we
have we have good evidence and i presume
that that evidence will grow
that the lunar cycle is actually
affecting our sleep um
we know that and it's you know it's not
just um
you know female typical sex hormones
that are cert that are that are changing
with you know along cycles that are the
same length of time as the lunar cycle
and that's no accident it's you know
there are a lot of our hormones for both
of us both of us
all of us are both sexes is what i meant
right um that that are that are cyclic
and
um it's it's going to be circadian it's
going to be lunar and it's going to be
seasonal as well and the seasonal stuff
will be you know there will be higher
peaks and lower
lows uh the farther from the equator
you're going to be totally
um i'm also uh always
uh keen to point out that in other
creatures
there are much less cryptic reasons for
these things
so lunar phobia in bats being
a great example if you go out and you
try to catch
bats you find that typically you get
many fewer bats
when you do so you know the fuller the
moon the fewer the bats
and the reason for this is typically
interpreted as
basically increased vulnerability to
visual predators especially owls
so the idea is the the you know
bats are nocturnal presumably
mostly because it hides them from their
predators
um and microbats at least have a
mechanism for navigating
at night that allows them not to be
hobbled by it so echolocation works very
well at night
there are some bats that navigate
visually and they have giant eyes but
in any case for most bats the advantage
of hunting at night um is
diminished when their predators have
a fair number of photons to go on and so
anyway
you get this lunar phobia effect
obviously human beings are not
likely to be sensitive for that reason
but the fact that we
remain sensitive is pretty pretty
interesting
well i wouldn't be surprised if there
weren't um
in different cultures um some
restrictions on
when particular types of hunts take
place regarding the moon
well you know both both because the moon
makes it easier to hunt and easier to be
hunted it's very rare for humans to hunt
at night um my guess would be so there
obviously are creatures that will lead
people
but they're also uh typically
typically cultural responses right like
the mythology that says
you know if a lion has hunted a person
that you have to kill
that lion because it has developed a
taste for human blood or whatever
and these things function presumably
very effectively to select
against the animals that experiment with
the hunting of people
um and so anyway you know you and i have
run into
crocodiles that could easily kill a
person that you know flee
sure in fear when we swim near them and
you know obviously mountain lions are
fully capable of
killing a person but they very rarely do
so but they're you know they're
famously and i don't remember which uh
witch fossils but you know they're
famously these you know
african fossils with the with the canine
holes from some large cat in their heads
having been you know having had some
hominid some early homing that have been
dragged up a tree
right i don't i don't actually remember
you know most most cats are diurnal
i think that was an australopithecine
and a leopard
um most cats aren't diurnal but i think
i think that was imagined to be yes a
leopard which
you know they're kind of crepuscular
they yeah i don't know yeah yeah
that was the case actually no they've
got the the cats have all the cats have
topedum lucidum
so um so they are they are presumably
better able to navigate at night than we
are
right but which is this reflection
efficiently
in the eye sufficiently early human
ancestor
that it's they were unlikely to have
mythology around um you know the
killing of animals that have killed
people uh so anyway
the question at least the hypothesis on
the table is that mythologies
that force people to kill
animals that have killed their kin
actually function to select against that
that they create a superstition or
something equivalent to it
in the wild animals that reduces the
hunting of people
all right are we there yep i think so
okay so we're going to take a 15-minute
break and then we'll be back with
our live q and a unless do you have a
thumbnail for this week
oh i do
but i don't have my phone on me um yes
we are going to have a
gorgeous thumbnail of a
bee in the late evening visiting flower
and what's the connection to today's
episode ah the connection is that the
bee
is uh preparing presumably given the
lightness of the yeah
do not even pretend that bees are
sleeping
we don't i don't i mean i think there's
some evidence that
i didn't i did not do my due diligence
on whether or not there's evidence that
be asleep in advance of this so i don't
want you just off the cuff claiming this
i'm sure there is be dormancy and that
this bee is headed for it
okay okay so we're going to be back with
our q a and
as soon as we can um this it takes a bit
longer with with odyssey
um so bear with us um you can ask
questions at darkhorsesubmissions.com
uh please consider joining one or both
of our patreons
tomorrow is the monthly private two-hour
q a on mine at 11am pacific
you can buy shirts at
store.darkhorsepodcast
email logistical questions like where do
i go again how do i ask questions
what's their po box at
darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com and please consider
subscribing to all four
of the channels that we are now um
either streaming on or having clips put
on which is to say both the main channel
brett weinstein's channel on both
youtube and odyssey and darkhorse
podcast clips
on both youtube and odyssey
like the videos share the videos and
remember to be good to the ones you love
and eat good food
and get outside be well everybody
you